some people are always in a hurry they  run when they could walk  race up steps when others take it slow  when joe biden's president america is  just going to have to keep  up just take it slow well president  biden could have used that advice  today but instead he decided to race up  the stairs to his airplane  and this happened  well it's kind of awful actually and  there's a certain amount of guilt in  replaying that the  i'm sure already seen it on the internet  today there are a couple levels on which  to assess is first is the political  clearly someone should be asking basic  questions about this remember when cnn  said the last president drank a glass of  water incorrectly and that was a sign he  was dying or something  or that walking slowly down a ramp was a  sign of a problem  doubt was there someone at cnn right now  trying to figure out how to tell us that  joe biden didn't actually  fall the white house is already trying  that they said it was the wind's fault